Today I have a message for the Turks.
Your government is fooling you into believing
that one day
you will become a member of the European Union.
Well, forget it.
You are no Europeans
and you will never be.
An Islamic state like Turkey does not belong to Europe.
All the values Europe stands for,
freedom, democracy,
human rights
are incompatible with Islam.
We do not want frisa
free travel for Turks coming to Europe either.
European governments that agree with this
will be voted out of office by the people.
Turkey voted for Erdogan,
a dangerous Islamist who raises the flag of Islam.
We do not want more,
but less Islam.
So, Turkey, stay away from us.
You are not welcome here.